today we recognize all 30 roberto
clemente award nominees who best
represent the game through positive
contributions both on
and off the field miguel cabrera proudly
receiving the nominee as the tigers
representative
earlier today and you'll see willie
castro wearing number 21. he will wear
21 miguel cabrera allowed to do the same
because of the roberto clemente nominee
and because willie castro is a native of
puerto rico as well matt manning is
going to make his 15th start for the
tigers this year he did not factor in
his uh in a decision his last start
on wednesday against pittsburgh
strikes out escobar for the first punch
out of the day brandon woodruff will
match up against his tiger lineup and
let's see how effective he'll be after
missing his last start three balls two
strikes on the tiger leadoff man akil
badou
woodruff deals and he got a big fastball
upstairs his first batter face is a
strikeout and a good start to the day
for woodruff
that's a foul tip it looked like it hit
the dirt but pina sold it as if he
caught it in the air which means a foul
tim strikeout
peterson delivers a base hit
clean single to center field
and the first hit of the game for
milwaukee
and he takes a ball and the brewers will
have two on now with two outs
single a steal and a walk
kane one for four had an infield single
last night one ball two strikes on
lorenzo kane
and he shoots one that is a fair ball
just inside the bag peterson will score
vogel back into third
and lorenzo kane with an rbi double and
the brewers finally get on the board
here in detroit is that a thing of
beauty or what how about that i mean
lorenzo kane just sticking the bat out
there
he's trying to put the ball in play
check that out i mean beautiful inside
the first base bag
another one two to one
to second base and matt manning does get
out of that bases loaded jam
milwaukee scores a run
tigers plenty of chances to get it back
gonna have to throw him out at first not
in time it's a strikeout
the 1-1
to center field
derrick hill is there there you go and
the brewers go quietly in the third two
to the count
got him change up yeah
castro swings and misses
seven in a row retired by woodruff
strikeout number three wrong the thing
about it is all of his secondary pitches
that he used to change up some really
good pitch both against left-handers but
he will use it against right-handers as
well another one got him that time 98
with a fastball
and hill strikes out 4k nine up nine
down the big woo
strikes out vogel back change up up and
away
a chopper
castro has to hurry
just in time good inning sure was nine
pitches credit to matt manning remember
the struggle in the second that took him
30 pitches
3-2 pitch and he chased that one down he
goes
brandon woodruff with five strikeouts
now 10 in a row retired to start this
game
the payoff to grossman
first base runner of the day for detroit
and it comes in the form of robbie
grossman in a two-hour walk in the four
here's miguel cabrera who grounded to
short his first time up there goes
grossman cabrera delivers a base hit to
left center field come on robbie's going
to hurry
santiago waving him home here's the
relay
it is not in time miguel cabrera
delivers the game-tying rbi here in the
fourth with two away
great base running timely hitting the
first hit of the game off of brandon
woodworth now 24 hits shy of 3 000
and extends his lead for most
interleague hits in major league history
the 27th pitch of the inning and another
3-2 and he finally got him a strikeout
to end the inning
well miguel cabrera the marches on to 3
000. miguel cabrera's rbi double just
tied it up
pina wasn't into that at bat down he
goes
and matt manning has four strikeouts on
the day
got him
struck him out for the second time today
the brewers go quietly in the fifth one
two three
to left field yelich hurrying it's gonna
drop in front of him
you like that i do like it all right
harold castro starts the fifth with a
single
squares de bunt lays it down
wong on the charge flips it bare-handed
and it gets by that's great running
castro really never stopped runners at
the corners for detroit runners at the
corners and nobody out
garnota left that's not yellow just got
it carol castro is going to tag throw
all the way home out in time castro's in
with a head first slide a sacrifice fly
from dustin garneau gives the tigers the
lead
derek kilbatting
this is to left center field that's
gonna find the alley willy castro will
score easily derek hill shifts into
overdrive on the way to third and he is
in there with a pop-up triple he
delivers yet again 3-1 tigers
very impressive base running from derek
hill here let's see
this ball is going to split the
defenders out in left center field
look at where
willie castro is already he's going to
score easily
but the way derek hill went around
second base
louis cerias the shortstop almost had
the ball in his glove
when derek hill
just touched second base
and yet his route
kind of brought him out away from third
base sliding back in towards his own
dugout
and he beat the throw to third he just
outran the baseball
would just trying to
muscle his way through five today
badou a swing and a foul tip right into
the middle of pina for a strikeout
there's a change up he got him
yes garneau held on to it off the foul
tip
and what a way to end the inning
dustin garneau delivered with his bat an
inning or so ago and now on this foul
tip keeping the concentration
and that'll bring up dustin garneau
same pitch sends it to left field and
deep yelich going back that ball's got
kerry it's gone how about that dustin
garneau a solo bomb with two out here in
the seventh and his extra
base hit barrage continues
very impressive at bat for dustin he
takes what would be the same pitch in
fact i'd argue that the last pitch the
one he hit might have been in a little
bit more but he sees it back-to-back
pitches and makes the adjustment
been pretty quiet in detroit
maria's into center field that's falling
fast and down for a base hit
finally the brewers have a safety in
this game that's their first hit since
the second inning yep and one more base
runner then somebody popped one
tenth pitch of the at-bat
he rings him up
beat him inside with that fastball about
belt high
here's the 2-2
fly ball right field deep
reyes is back that's a sweep of the
brewers
how do you like that
tampa comes to town tigers beat him two
out of three milwaukee comes to town and
the tigers broom them aside